these robots work 24 7 making a core
component used in commercial printers
for the Silicon Valley based company HP
we put two robot arms here and both arms
basically emulate a human hand and human
motion this Factory is in Singapore the
country ranks second in the world for
the number of robots that are deployed
for every 10 000 employees the
city-state's Embrace of automation has
helped keep at Bay many of the economic
challenges that the world is grappling
with right now from high inflation to
supply chain delays and labor shortages
automation can help with Rising business
costs both in the short term and the
median term so we visited the HP Factory
in Singapore to unpack the benefits and
risks of automating many manufacturing
processes with high-tech robots
what you see here is a machine that is
basically going to peel off an adhesive
tape that's sticking onto a pot right
now tangling Fung is the director of ink
cartridge operations for HP the company
opened this robotic manufact factoring
facility in 2017 making printheads that
dispense ink from cartridges the origin
of these Advanced robots dates back to
the 1960s a robot for industry back then
robotic arms were simpler mainly used to
assist with heavy lifting then in the
following decades they became more
advanced moving in one or two directions
and programmed to perform repetitive
tasks today HP has deployed alongside
some of the traditional robots these
newer robotic arms that are more
intelligent they're what the industry
calls collaborative robots or cobots
what cobots have changed is it literally
emulates a human function you have fine
degrees of freedom that you only a human
hand can do this dexterity allows the
arms to take on more complex tasks with
higher precision and work 24 hours a day
HP says it's been able to shrink its
Workforce so the manufacturing line has
more robots than people
Tang says the company has been able to
retrain its staff who now take on more
high-value jobs and work with robots
for instance if a production line stops
the employee investigates mechanical
problems so if you imagine cobots are
doing most of the physical work
the employees on the line are there to
help to monitor
and other staff verify Parts rejected by
robots this helps train the algorithm to
better inspect cartridges for defects
the company says since installing its
robotic manufacturing lines in Singapore
production costs have gone down by 20
percent
that kind of savings is important as the
world deals with inflation especially
for countries like the us where the rate
has remained stubbornly High we've seen
an extraordinarily High inflationary
pressures James Lambert is with Oxford
economics a Global Research firm that
provides analysis of the world economy
and he's been watching the impact of
automation for about a decade there have
been some unpredictable impacts on price
levels that happening
those unpredictable factors include the
lingering impact of the pandemic
and the war in Ukraine which has driven
up the price of energy and raw materials
in this inflationary context automation
is a solution for reducing operational
costs and creating a cost-effective
production chain that leads to cheaper
prices for consumers an efficient
production line is also about not
running short of Parts many companies
are dealing with a global supply chain
crisis where components have gotten
stuck at ports and suppliers can't
deliver them on time so HP is trying to
tackle that problem with automation too
by integrating these 3D printers what
we've done is we've been able to convert
this part which is metal and it had to
be manufactured as a supply and sent in
to a 3D printed pot Tang says this
method allows the company to bring the
supply chain closer to home and print
Parts on demand that was especially
critical during the pandemic when border
closures and supply chain backups hit
its production capability
but it's not easy to build a factory
like HP alternation requires large-scale
upfront capital investment not just in
the Machinery goals it often requires a
skills transition within the workforce
and that's where the government comes in
since about two decades ago Singapore
has identified Advanced manufacturing as
a priority and in 2016 the city-state
introduced incentives like tax breaks
for highly automated factories the
government is also facilitating research
Partnerships with universities and
subsidizing programs that retrain
workers Singapore government has been
really supportive they've helped to fund
this Center that we are sitting in
economists say Singapore's push to
automate can be inspirational since it's
a rare example of a wealthy country to
reverse a manufacturing downturn but
Lambert says this model may not be easy
to replicate everywhere there is a limit
to how much a continental sized economy
like the US with such a diverse
manufacturing base can learn from a
small localized focused city-state
economy like Singapore for instance in
Singapore's population of 5.5 million
has long relied on migrant labor to take
on manufacturing jobs
so the pain of transitioning to a highly
automated economy has largely fallen on
foreign Visa holders who head back to
their countries after their jobs
disappear before a populist country like
the US automating away jobs has faced
pushback from unions politicians and
displaced employees the political pain
that comes along with the social costs
of displacing workers for manufacturing
jobs can be much higher
economists say moving in a sharper
Direction like Singapore can be an
uphill battle and one of the keys to a
smooth transition will be taking care of
the human labor force it's going to be
invest in your people really look at how
do you upskill your employees equip them
with the knowledge first but more
importantly encourage that mindset shift
[Music]